hi everyone it's jerry i am on
leeches.org
and i'm going to hop into the eastern
super blitz arena
this is a
one hour 30-minute event of 3-0 chess
so we'll see who we get in
round number one
gm burr
let's go with a
french defense
queen e2 is stopping d5
and
i want to play this
and go for knight f6
prepared to try and work around a
a pawn there but they're not not doing
that
so what's the story here
throw my knight on e4
so i have a french
structure
this queen is a little misplaced my
knight will be challenged
i wonder if i could uh
maybe treat this as a pawn sacrifice
bishop to b4
i'll take
queen's still a little
a little weird
i'd like to get rid of this guy that's
for sure
my bad
bishop okay i guess some prep work for
an expansion
let's start with queen b6
all right
and
maybe i could work on these squares
i don't think there's any great drawback
with the knight a5
still two moves out from castling so is
white
i have c4 b3
tonight
if a knight is
on that b3 it's tough to contest this
file so
i like these two options
i'm also in a spot for this that was uh
probably the first thought that crossed
my mind but
the knight certainly has some forward
prospects
so if i play bishop here right now
knight here first
knight here in bishop a4 is interesting
knight here
knight here a5 a4
here right there i don't have much time
let's go for something straight
a bit more straightforward not as
sophisticated
okay
gotta take
and keep queens on
[Music]
all right we'll exchange oh no no oh i
was ready to blunder bishop takes bishop
and b no i had its queen takes queen
with check
okay
seeing ghosts here
so this is going to be the main
imbalance i'm anticipating these guys
will be exchanged
and at least one rook will be exchanged
let's go here
i need the flight square still
bishop here could maybe be a thing
this might have been a little too quick
i'll still sneak over bishop here if the
queen tries to infiltrate
i'll initiate the exchanges here my king
could help out in defending
the queen entry points
not sure how to approach this
let's put my pawns on light
down on time
let's insert this check
block
i don't know how to make forward
progress in his from this position
to watch out here
what's that night up to
trying to get
not sure what kind of break they're
going for
i didn't see that that was a yeah i'll
i'll take the draw for
it's a bit too locked
tough uh
first round opponent
that's for sure
leva that is
no i actually checked it out just before
that's uh they have it in their profiles
very strong we've played many times
so this is a pretty rare
okay i'm winning a piece here knight c6
what needed to be played
okay they resigned
this is a pretty rare thing for me to do
here
that is a
local record of
an eastern super blitz arena
normally i'm
doing these things while live streaming
and then uploading to youtube but
doing a local record this time around
359 in there
riddick 24 up next
all right
sicilian territory
i'll damage the structure and look
forward to having my pawn on c4 and e5
hopefully and i'm going to try and
play against the bishop so already i
have to take some steps to
make sure this guy doesn't come out and
about
i could still be pushed away and this
this path can be cleared
but i'm going to try and make that
difficult
at the very least i have a good outpost
on c4 if my knight needs to go
so i i'm actually all right with this
okay so they're allowing me to take
their dark square bishop
i think i'll jump at that chance
and put another knight on c4
this is not not there just yet i have a
double attacking move so
if i can control the
this pawn from getting to e5 i am
basically
controlling this bishop
uh that move
um
let's duck that particular exchange
another thing to note i guess is that if
we enter an opposite color bishop
position
um
i'm kind of still cool with that too
my dark square bishop i believe is one
that
will find a much more productive role in
this environment within this structure
so i have an unopposed dark square
bishop
and it usually makes a lot of sense to
throw that guy right
on the main diagonal so right here is a
very sore spot
black certainly needs to take some care
knight f4 i feel like a workaround the
knight is not connected with any other
black piece
this structure does a good job of
controlling the bishop
i have extra protection over this knight
and i could look for maybe some
aggressive moves
right now
i don't believe knight b4 will be a
very disruptive
there's no f6 because i have an
in-between check
also that's creating a big gap on g6 so
tough to really boot this knight away
i guess we'll begin with
i do something
a little different
about queen here hits the bishop in the
pawn
i feel like
queen's kind of
going astray if she plays there
i don't think uh upon advance of c4 is
going to be
very disruptive sometimes this can
happen so the bishop can
get on the main diagonal like this guy
is
all right
let's
let's simply centralize for right now
i'd like to get i'd like to land some
trick against g7 but i'm just not seeing
seeing that just yet if i move my knight
to exchange queens
i mean i could go for that and then try
and track down some of these weak pawns
i'm thinking a little bit less about
that now that i've inserted this flight
square though because i would much
rather if i'm in exchange queens
rather be recapturing towards the center
so now that this pawn has advanced it's
a bit more accessible to my bishop and
knight so
even though i may be taking away from
the center after cleaning okay so hang
on what if i what if i begin with
i'll go for it with
i'll make some uh weaknesses in my
position i don't think the
these gaps i've created namely the the
hole on e3
is uh
is accessible or is uh is can be taken
advantage of
so
there can be pressure here
looking at queen f2
maybe even this
a bishop here is landing a skewer knight
on b4 could interfere with that
22 seconds for my opponent so now
they're making life a little bit easier
for me
because i get to step up here this is a
a square that black no longer has
control over with their last move
they're eyeing up f5 which is a good
post for the knight but structurally
this is very rough for black
and i'm pretty sure losing
get to actually the rook is trapped
an awesome time issue
so we'll swipe the rook first
take with the king if we're gonna have a
queen exchange
and
i guess this one's
going to end soon
i'll defend like that this knight seems
to be a pretty good
a convenient defender
of the c2 pawn
okay
we continue
the bird is being thrown my way
f4
an accelerated
accelerated dutch
all right where do i want my dark square
bishop
and go for this
i'm going for this because
well let's let's go here i want to be in
a spot to meet a4 with a6
uh i'm gonna go here my idea is that i'm
opening up a new square for the bishop
i'd like to develop with chuck
and if i can provoke this move i'm i'm
happy
because this was really their idea but
now
now it's not so easy to get in
i'm going to play here
not here i'm keeping this open for my
knight
this is the big square right now in the
position so they're getting that move in
and i guess we're going to take oh
they're taking like that that's
interesting
hmm
yeah i think that that's a good idea
all right i think i need to
be careful
now what do i play here
hmm
all right i guess we're gonna chop
okay
now i have to be very careful
i definitely have to be careful
hmm
uh i don't really like my position this
has opened up i didn't they they were
able to get an e4 there so
uh
yikes
we got back off don't allow that knight
to exchange so easily
yeah let's hang on to this guy
oh
of course they have this yeah i wanted
i wanted a card here
okay knight f6
or here
that's my light square bishop this is
gonna be a problem
uh
yeah that's that's looking pretty good
too
i almost don't even want to
uh let's go here
yeah
i'm in trouble
i'm realizing i'm covering this square
at least
i'd like to
hopefully close down this position a
little bit
it's not going to be easy
i believe i'll be losing a pond soon
yep
not much i could do about that
i think i have to castle
no matter what i do i feel like i'm in
trouble
on the clock and position
i need more time
to execute what i wanted to do get some
maneuvers in but yeah that was that was
way off
i don't think their last couple moves
have helped their position a whole
there's lot checks here
um
i've tricks
i'm close to having tricks the king a
lot of stuff is on dark squares yeah
queen c5 could land
maybe something good this bishop by the
way
is short on squares i'm just realizing
i'm threatening this right now
that move
okay
can i work with that how can i uh
oh
i'm giving the bishop this square am i
doing
yeah
didn't really gain a whole lot with that
sequence
i have only helped my opponent
that's it
yeah this is busted
clean checks have a perpetual at minimum
at minimum perpetual
oh
nice move
oh yeah they have that too okay i should
be resigning
ago down on time and position
guess that idea to play the check
that time waste
bishop checked bishop back that e4 move
came too fast
i could have played it a little
different
even after that break was in not
allowing them to get that my light
square bishop
but i still
i still wasn't really going to be
enjoying my position there
because
the the main thing is that the position
was opening up and i was way too behind
in development
all right on we go
i don't have any great discoveries
against the queen i guess we could try
this
go after the b pawn isn't that queen a
little short on squares
force the queen's off it feels like it's
really close to that
wouldn't mind a queen exchange i'm
taking with this rook get off of this
diagonal
let's play here i think this is where
there's likely to be some
files opening up
see if they take me
this bishop is their best piece
okay
let's keep playing on the queen side
uh that guy again best piece let me try
and get rid of it
bishop d6
then it feels a little bit more i feel a
little bit more comfortable
moving my brooks out and about okay so
things are heating up or moving moving
about on the queen side
those those two guys working on adjacent
diagonals were scaring me
i think it makes sense to maybe i could
take control over the only open file
i'm there first right
if we chop and then rook c6 i already
have the battery going on
i have to take some extra care over this
square so if the knight is able to get
there in timely fashion
could be in some
trouble and he's going for that
i see
i'll go with rook here i want to watch
out for this square knight here into d3
c5
the number one square that has my
attention right now is c5
they're playing this well
um
i don't know if i really mind giving up
my light square bishop
they're supporting a knight jump into c5
i guess i'm gonna have to work around it
maybe work some magic on the f2 square
oh i have this
maybe like yeah my knight helps to fight
the c5 square
other they also have that
all right suppose we start with this
first though
how to recapture
uh
i don't want the passer i want to track
this guy down
yeah that one okay we'll get the light
square bishops off
i guess get rolling how do i want to
break
i guess we'll go like this
i want to pass her on the outside
hmm
i don't see any great entry points
okay what if this
i want to do that
break up their pawns like this oh i get
a pawn like that
this was not calculated
i want my knight back to targeting this
guy though
i don't know if the timing is going to
be there hopefully
our pawns are
we're going into pac-man mode oh they
didn't defend that pawn
not sure why not
down on time
okay
i want a night exchange can we get that
i get this break in
not gonna be easy
it's looking like a draw
yep
yeah that'll do it
oh they're going for a win
oh
that's that's trouble for them
they were going for the win
that is still it is still possible to
win on time there
sneaky guy
all right
lucked out with the
a win there i'm still in search of a
four
one two two zero
in 74th 659 in there
there's your first page
burr has slipped up who knocked him off
timu
all right
an hour six to go
let's try d4
armada bcm in first is 22.
that's a little odd
quick development for the bishop
all right i'm gonna go straight for
an attack against the knight
i'll go with that
my instinct says
i was thinking
just go with e4 straight away open it up
in that earlier game my opponent
blundered they didn't play that knight
c6 move
different story in this game i have the
bishop pair
and they're taking pretty quick there i
like that i get to recapture with my
bishop on its first move
these tricks
queen c2 if they go for that
form some battery i want i want to open
some lines
so now this knight is nailed down for at
least a move maybe they flick in a
flight square
let's go with this i probably want to
insert both a4
c4 i might want to give up my dark
square bishop for the night i don't know
how productive it'll end up being
huh
i'm actually going to
i feel like it might not even have a
great role in this game if i don't get
rid of it right then and there
so i'll play with this
inbounds
i'll get my flight square and i don't
want to see knight g5 if i have to play
that yeah i'd rather this
okay and if i play here
um let's reposition my bishop get it out
of this stuff
bishop on f3 offsets the knight
all right i could play here i could chop
first here knight b4
before here knight before
yeah there's something then i can't be
supported
knight before queen b3 and if they go
here here i win the b5 pawn
so what i'm doing with this last move is
eliminating my weakest pawn
no great forks looking at these forward
moves these are the main ones on the
queen side i'm
looking at these are both isolated and
weak
these are the three ice isolated points
rook on the seventh
maybe
maybe this first
to stop this and then
they may be close to gluing in the
knight on b5
they may be going for c4
if i could saddle black with an isolated
d-pawn i'd be a fan i think now
i think the knight's going to return to
d5 let's let's still go here
knight d5 maybe then i take
if this pawn is backward i
i'm i'm cool with that
still looking for
something here
uh i want to be able to bite it
something
create some weakness okay so i have a
pawn
exchange rooks first and then take here
i like getting one rook off take with
the queen and keep my rook in the corner
move my queen and push away
my bishop controls the corner square if
this guy ever moves threatening another
pawn
see no reason not to take here pressure
on f2
but that's it
these are offset i just have to watch
out for the queen sneaking in even if
this ends up falling
shouldn't really be that big of a deal
because i have this covered
very well
but i should probably not even allow
that in the first case
so i'm going to make
a pretty defensive looking move stop the
queen from even getting to a point where
she gets here
and i'm still
i have a clear plan up two pawns rook
ideally placed now good coordination
all across the board
probably just swipe this knight
yeah let's take them out
make sure there's no tricks
and let's get rolling
yeah the queen going back
i ended up getting the rook
here here queen in the corner of the
rook falls in the end
yeah two jobs too many has to stop the
pawn and defend
something's gotta give
oh no
okay
not a clock ticker
all right let's let's make it
very
very clean
get the coins off
all right they resigned
i'm back to tournament land an hour to
go that first hour our first half hour
flew by
i've got nine
i don't think i'm gonna berserk any
games
just trying to get some
some good
good games in there
it is possible to win with without
berserking
it's happened before
but uh
it's not very likely with that early
loss there
we'll see though
what do i want to do here
stop b4 for just a move
uh
i'll go with this queen d7
okay so
this square
i could try and work with
hop in right away
and
let's move this knight
okay
i think that's a
that's maybe an issue because i get this
clamping down move the queen and knight
are no longer on that so
these guys are frozen this knight should
find
a nice home here
uh
i'm going to support
the knight with the b pawn
i want to take towards the center
all right they're going to go there
[Music]
that's a good move
hmm
all right
i have to have to watch out for that
move that this wasn't a good move i was
just kind of playing some hope chest
there that i'd be able to get this
exchange i think a better approach would
be to stop my bishop g
g5 idea and only then proceed
so what do i want to do from here
i want to close down the king side if i
can
let's start with this
g5 f6 or actually the order should
probably be f6 g5
my queen can be challenged let's start
with f6
because i'm winning structurally
speaking on the
queen side
okay so the queens are off
and now
now
maybe i don't care to even close it up
let's um
let's begin with this night now maybe i
like keeping the knight here for a
second let's try this kind of break a
rook on b3 exerting pressure on these
two weak points
this guy
trying to play against him
maybe it was wiser to play g5 i'm not
sure
gotta do something quick anyhow those
are the the two plans that quickly cross
my mind
uh
let's do it now yeah let's be consistent
said a let's go with b
hmm
[Music]
okay that's a pawn
and that's another pawn
i think i'm being gifted
many pawns here
on the rook
defend here now i'm on this pawn i don't
really want to take that though
take on poisson i'm on this yeah they're
missing some stuff here
okay
let's let's go here and control the
bishop
all right they resigned yeah they went
astray there
uh again i was i made up
i guess i in a way i was playing hope
chess briefly there when i played bishop
f6
because after h4 it kills my idea and
i'm
obstructing my f pawn
and i probably end up having to undo it
that f5
move our f4 move was good on their part
didn't really like how i played that one
okay let's get the guy
the the bad guy out and about
i like my position
better c pawn
better queen bishop
i'll go here
maybe they take
i get to recapture in one
uh okay
no my queen initially came there to
support this pawn to to avoid
to avoid the uh
you know some variations where they
they're taking there now
i know i just ducked this exchange i'm
kind of
playing it like
that this bishop is still so good it's
going to need to be challenged
right
i'll exchange now and now this maneuver
that i'm going for is what i
i was trying to do in that game that i
lost
i think i'll be able to
get in this sequence of moves i was
trying for in that game
this is a big uh this is a big gap
i could jump in i've
i've been in a spot where i could have
jumped in for a couple moves now
i also have this square
which is helpful if they try and
challenge yeah
so i'll go with this right now and the
the big difference here is the e
e4 and e5 squares
so
what about them exactly
it's that e5 is not a hole but e4 is a
whole
isn't a hole for black is a hole for
white
i have the better bishop too
all right
how to improve
so here first is that queen oh she's
actually quite short on squares let's
let's go with this idea
all right
okay they're going to challenge my name
i'm gonna try
um exchange and then play in the center
here
let's try this
need a break
g5
queen on this square should be pretty
good
i could also consid yeah let's stop this
move
let's consider
this move right now
or do i baby step it
maybe maybe we still focus on the queen
side this break or
i may want to i may want to close it
down completely keeping my options open
still at this moment
bishop's unprotected
i'm in a pin here
let's try this
i'm going with the less least committal
moves first
okay i'm going to try this now
here and then here
still have options though
okay that move
yeah let's give it a go
i'm already opposite there they're king
let's take with the bishop i want to
keep this file opened
now i think that this is going to be
tough to defend
we'll see
i don't want the queen giving check i i
like i want to double up first and then
maybe
pull the trigger on this
okay
where's the mate is there mate
let's take
winning upon
that really enough
check i fall back
i want the queens off
check on g5
getting the queens off
be careful
if i could get here i win and i should
be getting there i have a tempo too
that's important
in some cases i think i think in this
one
not even having a tempo should have been
all right
10 seconds
actually i think the cleanest win
is the one that just is going to go
right to me
yeah
i get to go like that they could once
they move their b pawn i take and then
their c or a pawn
if i take with my c pawn their c pawn
has moves if i take with my a pawn their
a pi a pawn has moves
and i'll be mating
in a couple from there i got 17 and
first is 26 40 just under 50 minutes to
go
okay
sicilian maybe we go closed sicilian
all right
early pawn moves i think these are all
healthy
they've basically stopped my uh bishop
from coming out and about
all right night there is a little
unusual
if i play f5 right now
let's go with that f5 my queen is after
all opposite the king
and i'll take
i don't know at least i don't have to
worry about that knight going to d4 as
easily
all right
i guess we castle
uh i could have considered something
else though maybe let's do it now take
take here
and then we have this queen h5 check
queen's getting here
it's not the end of the world though
for black they have queen d4 which
solves everything oh
not everything they'd still be down a
pawn
all right let's start with that one
and take
here
getting a second pawn
so they're better than a queen exchange
could support my queen
i like that idea
queen exchange still can't be avoided
and i'm in a spot to exchange light
square bishops
that i'd like to have happen
light square bishop exchange and a
knight right here
let's get the rook on the only open file
i guess they're trying rook d6
yeah rook d6
can i be a pest queen here
yeah
let's give that a go
i have the safer king
the queen can't go too far
we'll see okay uh
i guess we're getting the queens have to
come off now
or
no i could i could get i could sneak in
here
i'm still in the spot to play this move
there's a check on d4
but again there'd be a problem here oh
so i got the exchange
uh exchange queens now i guess and just
put the nine in the center
okay
so it should be clean from here i could
give my rook back i have a couple pawns
i'll go here i want c4
they should try
this so i don't get that one in but now
connected passer straighten the pawns
out
and the approach should be pretty clean
they might have been ready to move the
bishop and put the king here so just
want to demote the king in some way
it goes back or here
the king is there to offset
flush it back further
put everything on light to start
this guy won't hurt me
and improve
i guess here
king up flush the king back
threatening mate
let's go here first
then this
can't stop it
okay
that's a fast pairing
let's try c4
just under 45.
there should be four or not no bishop b4
a3
let's play d4 now
yeah that bishop post is making me think
a bit more about this push
or even
or even this recapture with tempo
thinking
i'm thinking about opening up this
diagonal now all right is this coming
too slow
what i'm doing here
i guess it is uh
c5 uh
yeah i don't have anything out of the
opening
i guess we could start with this though
be patient for a move with this tension
okay wait
take here
let's go with this
bishop f6
i guess we exchanged queens
yeah let's exchange
so this is very dull
only a structure imbalance
i guess we'll queenside castle i don't
know if i like that
bishop here's annoying
i could develop my uh my bishop
because if this i have that g7 square in
mind this is my best piece coordinated
really well with my queen side
should be balanced position
okay let's go king's side
bishop b3 is still a little annoying
maybe
maybe i go here
yeah
their bishop's too good or it's gonna be
too annoying
so
i guess i'm
okay
with uh let's expand before this is
stopped and i also have this square f3
cozy home there light square
so my my reasoning i guess is
it was okay
to uh
damage my pawns just to eliminate that
light square bishop that i
was anticipating was gonna be a bug
hmm
let's go here
i like that move b5
i'm not sure about that one though
because i have something to bite at i
have checks threatening the pawn
whoa
allowing me to take that
my rook is
out of control now
close to mate maybe
coordination
yeah it's definitely gifted
that pawn
let's insert a quick check
okay i have some tricks now take here
and then have this follow up
bishop c5
they're in a pin
so let's keep it for a move
oh no no no no no let's take this pawn
now we have a two to one majority on the
queen side
keep those pins
all right
that's a slick move
huh
i didn't know if i was going to be
winning if i took like that so now i
have my work cut out for me still
i'm pretty sure i know how to win this
but
i i wanted the king and pawn ending
what am i doing just push this guy and
create a past e-pawn
and that'll win
past e pawn
will do the trick
the king tries to stop it then i get
that
fancy skewer
11 seconds
to do it
not super confident with being able to
pull off these games
compared to if i wasn't recording
because computer goes a little slower
very often doesn't go as smooth okay
they resigned
didn't test my uh my mouse
25 with fire 34's in first
39 minutes to go
hand check one we've played a couple
all right they're allowing e5
and let's play with
let's play with the quick f5
how do i want to recapture
we'll go with the pawn
it's already a little scary knight f6
stopping this
bishop there
i feel like i'm okay with the dark
square bishop exchange let me offer dark
square bishop exchange
i may want to take with my queen
i think i want to try that
turning the bishop
maybe it backs off and says this guy's
clumsy
yeah that's cool
all right
connect to my knights
i'm also stopping knight to h4
let's go here
maybe sneak my queen over i want to be
careful of knight b5 though here knight
b5 i might want to flick in a6 first
this i'm gonna meet with that i'm pretty
sure
okay that's
yeah they're definitely getting ready
for
a piece drop on that square
maybe i uh
hmm
yeah let's go for it
they've weakened themselves a little bit
try and pry at that g pawn
and back off
maybe they don't even win that pawn now
i like
just before i played this move i was
thinking to myself well i'm opening up
this guy's eyes bishop g4 can really
sting could try and work on some pin i'm
expecting at some point c3 to control
the knight and also open up a queen
check
knight f5 can also be pretty good in
this position
uh
there let's let's get a fast mover in
there
should i play
g5 you know what i think i like g5
take away this
this square from these nights
are they really going for this move oh
they're going for that
i don't want to
i don't want to take though
i want to keep this file open so
and now with this in it's tough to get
out of the pin i mean the queen can move
right now because the bishop babysits
and maybe it's necessary that white
get out of the pin right now okay that
one so i could take the light square
bishop
and then give a check with my queen
maybe i keep him in a pin
it's getting
sharp rook g1 is nearby
i feel like this was not a wise choice
tell you what we'll take
and then i'll play here i'll still leave
the leave this check opened this king
can't feel too comfortable on h3
i want to take here
the rook on f4 would be very good a rook
or a knight and i think i'm getting one
of the two
a lot of pieces
that are just moments away from maybe
doing something against their king this
guy is not yet playing this guy will
soon be their best piece i believe
feel that those knights are under
control
so hopefully that's the case
this rook is doing
a lot of good
we'll get the check in
double rooks double trouble
where's the king go g2
now the rook in the corner
isn't going to be productive
but i could see why you would want to go
here hugging these pieces
some some defense there
i push this knight away
push here push here
let's try for something
to watch out for the checks
queen on f5
feels right
looking at this
i want to make this night budge
this opens up squares for my bishop my
knight my bishop's pinned
i feel like he's just a a pawn for right
now
queen b3 how am i reacting to that so if
i push right now
what's the story here
this is not yet a threat got the king in
between
maybe they're moving the king right now
i could defend with rook here
maybe i could even allow the capture
no i probably want to defend and then
crash through on f2 third down on time
it's got sharp real fast
okay let's let's take here first
and take here
defend here
or simply take the knight
taking the knight was an option
pawn knight
rook
how's it all defended i'm hitting
everything actually
take a pawn
okay they're down on time
that got way way sharp early
all right
32 to go
over a thousand in here approaching 1200
in seventh
let's try d4
twitch fish chess
fifth time playing
uh let's go with this
c4 is probably one of the most popular
ones
okay i like those structures that i end
up getting
i think bishop e7 instead of d6 is the
way i like going for this
those of you who are more positionally
mind
minded me
may take a liking to this
this thing here
a knight on d5 playing against this d6
pawn backward pawn
i have an option to take here and then
win the d6 pawn
and i think i'll actually go for that
there's no bishop move with check
we're on opposite colors
this guy can't move with chuck
queen exchange i'll go for that
and
let me let me first
go here i want to get rid of the
pressure on this point it's kind of
awkward
and
let's get this move in try and justify
this move my knight will be kicked back
but at least i'm saying now my f pawn is
playing
uh this this is now a new square i'm
realizing
i'm okay with this exchange
i'm i'm forcing that i could have my
pawns constructed on dark i want to open
up this diagonal for my bishop
let's do it right now
knight there
didn't uh i didn't anticipate that one
could go here
i don't think there's any tricks knight
here b3 rook check king here and then i
win a piece
okay
and now
we simply can test this file
it's close to a king and pawn ending
like if we exchange both rooks and then
i get my bishop right here the knight is
dominated
and i get to play b4
i guess they have that but
all right maybe maybe we continue to
push
so my pawns may end up on light squares
but if i have a connected passer
and
a connected passer that deep
there's problems so this is a one king
and pawn ending basically should i
insert the check
i don't think so
i'm gonna keep this duo as
is well actually why not
let's let's flick in the check
because my my bishop is now
squashing both knight and king
threatening to win the pawn
and i'm able to win
here let me just make sure if i could
get my king
b4 yeah i could win this pawn too
yeah let's do it
also go here
and i'm going to go here and just say
the knight's dead
now we'll go here
46 seconds
going back and forth with my
thoughts there
hmm
let's keep going i don't think it's
really necessary to move upon over here
i'll go with this guy
i don't want to give that square up
that earlier game where the king was
kind of stalemated and there was some
pawn play that would
you know
allow for them to have an
uh
a move with one of their pawns
that's not quite going to be the case
here
their pawns are too close to mine
alright they resigned
chewed up a lot of time going back and
forth on uh
what what approach to take in that
position in the ending
king and pawn ending or not
maybe if i if i could do it over again i
wouldn't have inserted the check when
the rooks were in tension with that one
try d5 oh
we played oh that was that oh yeah right
that sharp game
we're back at it
another game
much much much more tame in this game
controlled
not concerned about the checks with the
bishop or queen
i don't mind the double g pawns
sometimes there's a concern if the
knight could get to g5 queen on h4 but
it's a little
a little farfetched
seems like this will likely open up
c8
feels like it's uh
more of a robotic move oh let's let's
let's centralize
okay but now they're now they're
actually justifying
their idea is playing uh this one next
i see
all right let's take here
have the queen opposite my queen
because then if they get the e5 break in
i can take and then the queens come off
it still should remain pretty equal
maybe they
take here first
okay let's see what they do
they're gonna be better
let's get the queens off
yeah they're gonna have an active rook
maybe i get the uh flight square in the
process
uh yeah we're taking with the bishop
taking with the bishop
bishop h6 is
annoying white is clearly better
i think i have to try for
no it's not quite back rank mate
i guess rook d8 and my king goes for
this little tight walk
tightrope walk
a night
a night game coming up
exchange king here rook here
[Music]
no here i want to keep the rook on i
think
huh
that one
okay
if i take
here
okay i wanted i want to keep the knights
on
it's reminding me of a recent rapid game
i played where
there is this idea my opponent could
potentially give check and then step up
i don't really have any better than this
draw i don't want to see the rook hit
over here
yeah i i can't justify avoiding that
repetition so even though it's not
uh great for the tournament standings i
think that's just the objective
best that i could do there
i didn't really appreciate that rook to
d1 move i was
my immediate reaction was quite critical
of it but
i should have reacted a little
differently there maybe maybe capturing
first on d4
and then once they have a fixed pawn on
that d4 square
then i can proceed
something i have to be careful about
here is this g4 move
yeah
uh maybe even still right now huh
that's hitting pretty fast
let's go here
already in trouble
no
okay
feels like they've played this one
before
suppose i begin with bishop here
all right it's getting a little scary
here with these pawns
they've already or just 11 moves in and
they have two pawns in my house now this
i think is big trouble for white because
i could
throw my pawns i can lock down the king
side
and my king's going to have a very safe
square on g7 this guy is
in rough shape
queen side castle i need to get out of
this pin otherwise the knight jumping in
like this will be
super painful holy smokes
didn't see that one coming
wow
chopped knight takes queen here knight
f6 check
there's also a push
maybe i could
let's begin with this one
i don't know
maybe take one move later
all right let's try it now
still going to be scary
no doubt
queenside castle
yepper
if there's an aggressive move oh
it's just saying if there's an
aggressive move my opponent is going
with it right away
well i'm toast here
didn't see that
that hurts
i think they should have flicked in a
check
how many pawns am i down one
is there hope
i grab that knight
knight might be close to trapped
stay focused here
could take i take the night then they
have something fancy
not sure why i didn't go here
well way down on the clock
oh
long road ahead here for me
wow
man
well they just take my phone
easy enough
plenty of ways to do it
sneaky guy
one second is not a lot
smokes
oh man
nine lives
don't know how i pulled that one off
it's beat many times over
all right 17 minutes to go
lucky
lucky
all right
bononi
yeah they're getting that move in
and it's comfortable
for black
already
this guy really doesn't
do a whole lot
i've made life way too easy here for
black
okay
what am i going for long term
not really sure
i guess we're going to try for this
in d5 i have to
i have a central majority
can we do something with that
push and then f5 might be a thing
um
yeah let me first do this
bishop controls this night i have to be
prepared to swipe the night
just getting off of this diagonal for
starters
okay night i think i need to take
my guy oh so they're gonna give up the
dark square bishop
is that the thing i have this square now
too
yeah
take well i think they missed that this
was a move
if i get pushing
put the knight our bishop on d4
knight right here is gonna be powerful
queen in the center
first
if i go here there's knight takes e4 i
push
i'm gonna push rook takes pawn
takes pawn
oh there's night check here
yeah they see it
whoa
queen takes knight it's not really
helping
i'm toast here
that's pretty clean
i'm in a pin and i cannot get out of it
okay
hmm
any tricks
for one trick
uh maybe this
save my rook at least
get out of the pin with check
way down on the clock
you probably take
might be closer to it
yeah
time though
trying to cut off their king with my
last move
feels like objectively it might be a
draw
it's time though
why'd i go there
oh
oh man that night getting into d3 was
brutal
well
that opening play by me was very bad
um i didn't get a good setup at all
that's for sure
uh
they got everything they wanted
so that's definitely something they need
to work on
because that was
it felt like it went right by even and i
was already better for black
once we got to a certain point
they get rid of their light square
bishop too easily
they get that c4 moving space
too much good stuff
all right 11 minutes to go
not easy working around this guy
try and resolve this tension
bishops are scaring me
all right don't hurt me
put the rook here i feel like my knight
wants to
let's do this
threaten mate there
okay
getting sharp
let's let's start with this actually
because now if the queen can't go to h4
and queen here i have a bishop g5
be very careful about my dark squares
now okay so i have at least
pulled the queen away from seeing h7
this idea that idea
chop here
all right
maybe
okay
i'm hoping
playing a little hope chess with this
move
hoping for something like that yeah
okay this was my idea to have this
double attacking move
i felt like that rook maybe needed to
defend the knight but it's it's still
scary over here oh cool there's queen
back that defends
i didn't see that one
okay
get this guy
put my rook here my queen for the moment
is really only functioning like a
a rook
take with the knight
uh
i'll keep with the pawn
knight on f8 no mate
like i just want to take that knight
let's get rid of them
pins
right here pins
so fixated just right then and there
with
i was thinking oh they're going to land
a skewer now that guy's still pinned
the tri rook here
now
if i drop this queen right here
activate my knight
let's go here first
no i shouldn't have done that
let's come back
keep my rook defended oh my goodness
they're unpinned with that last move
that was horrible
i'm trying for perpetuals that aren't
there
and i'm down on time
oh that was such an awful sequence
very bad
man that was really bad
okay
holy smokes bishop f1 unpinned
yeah
okay i'm out of page one eleventh here
the goal i guess is going to be to try
and get to page one
nearly fourteen hundred in here
one final game hopefully will count
need a two
get on page one burr is running away
with it 68.
all right final game
see how it goes
overall not uh
very happy with how i'm playing
but
it's not easy
not easy playing and trying to provide
some commentary so i like that i have
this in bishop on e3 knight here and now
i could go for
this king side expansion
i don't foresee the center opening up in
a way that's going to
really be getting at my king
they may be temp they may be ready to
try for something like that um
sacrifice here actually g5 chop chop
chop chop this f5 move f4
is actually nearby
let's go with f3
the the one of the downsides i see with
f3 is that if i were to play g5 they
have knight h5 but not after this move
so this is a
very good structure to get in
let me challenge their best piece
i've played this position
this structure before where i have given
up my good bishop for this knight
but it's in a different
excuse me it's a little different with
the uh
i've done that when there's like a hole
on b5
and there's some some kind of lockdown
i have with a4 i'm going here so that i
could reroute to this square and once
more challenge the knight
all right i guess we'll try for this and
get my b-pawn rolling
um
actually let's go one step first i want
my knight on d3
but if i do that right away my bishop is
blocked
okay let's go here
i basically just sit okay so now it's
closed on the queen side a bit more
um
let's go here
that's your home king
323
rook a1 is what i'm prepared to play
i'll take
try and work on this guy
hmm
wow
all right let's try and open it up
these bishops are covering squares
sometimes this can be a move
to get that e5 square i might i have
enough on this
i have three on that one they miscounted
i guess
just one upon
i try bishop here to grant the rook some
squares
i'm gonna fall back here i could take
that pawn but i want this guy around to
defend some squares near my king
case things get crazy
get to the open file
and push this guy
that's the big
the big plan
stop queen here
first
i guess they're ready for some fancy
stuff
which by this point oh no actually i
have this rook takes pawn might have
been a thing
let's keep pushing
takes pawn
all right let's get rid of this guy he's
a potential block hater
my knight and bishop complement each
other really well on this these files on
this file
and from here
could go here rook on f6 now that
there's no dark square bishop
rick on f6 with this push
rook takes knight i should be aware of
as well
let's get going
could have captured here oh no no no i'm
in a spot to capture there
go with that guy
57 seconds
let's take here
i feel like i don't even want to take
that bishop
get the queen
20 seconds
can i get this game in
gotta capture the rook too
barely
alright did i get the first page i did
okay
a buzzer beater
eighth overall 1404 in there
burr
my first round opponent took it
had a couple losses in there
me too
it was my final
standing
two draws two losses
and some wins
17 games
overall
let's have a look at the top 100
say good games all
soon
page two three
four five so a little bit different of a
video
than when i'm streaming and playing
all right
maybe it's uh something i'll i'll do
once in a while we'll see
good games all
all right
you